you're not hearing a lot about this but
the country disney won't criticize
communist china is subjecting their
citizens to apocalyptic scenes now this
video is truly shocking we've not
independently verified it but it was
allegedly recorded in jinan city and
shangdong province on april 1st
it shows citizens on their knees waiting
for chinese storm troopers to scan their
vaccine passports and in shanghai the
city of 26 million is under a complete
lockdown because of mostly asymptomatic
covet cases omicron variant everyone is
required to be tested and if you test
positive you're taken away to a
quarantine camp
but that's not foolproof after getting
an abnormal test result one woman spent
16 hours on a bus to one of these
facilities and during the trip she had
no food or water my only wish is to
leave this place alive she told the wall
street journal reporter things aren't
much better for the lucky ones who test
negative the economist don weinland is
saying uh in a shanghai hotel and he
said he ran out of water he tweeted they
advised me to buy online but these
delivery services have stopped
and lawyer jared nelson says he wakes up
at 6 a.m to try to order food and water
deliveries when he finally got one to go
through he received six potatoes one
onion one clove of garlic and four
tomatoes
it was the most food his family had in
six days
joining me now is arkansas senator tom
cotton senator
your reaction to this
well i feel terrible for all the chinese
people who are yet again being oppressed
by their own government remember though
laura this government did something very
similar in the early days of the
coronavirus two years ago they were
locking people in apartment buildings
welding the door shut
from the outside the chinese government
uh has no one to blame but themselves
for unleashing this plague on the world
um that's why they continue these absurd
covet zero policies
you know though it kind of reminds me of
the way the democrats try to use
coronavirus for their own political
purposes here in america laura you know
for two years they shut down our schools
and our businesses if we let them stay
in power this fall they'll keep doing it
after the election is over but you know
you look in the senate they want 10
billion dollars of more spending for
corona virus it's an emergency they want
kids and head start programs to wear
masks it's an emergency they want you
and your toddler on an airplane to wear
a mask it's an emergency yet they want
illegal aliens to cross their border oh
it's not an emergency anymore the
democrats have been using this
coronavirus for their own political
purposes for many many months now
senator disney of course was trashing
florida and the florida law about not
telling kids about sexual identity from
five to eight years of age they're
outraged about that
but disney shanghai of course make
disney makes a lot of money from disney
shanghai and
you don't hear disney criticizing china
but we hear tonight just a few moments
ago
news.com in australia is reporting that
china has been
harvesting
organs of prisoners new research
published by the australian national
universities matthew robertson
suggesting that some of the prisoners
were likely still alive when the organ
removal surgery began
he's a renowned and respected source
senator
where are the womb corporations making
all the money in china speaking out on
harvesting organs from prisoners who are
alive who then end up dying essentially
executing them by organ harvesting
yeah laura it's grotesque
these reports are consistent with
reports that have come out of china for
years they engage in organ harvesting
against prisoners in many cases
political prisoners who don't tow the
party line but of course corporations
like disney and the nba are more
concerned about their bottom line they
are taking a genuine principled stand
so if they think it will help them
appeal to a bunch of liberals especially
the liberals that work for them they're
more than happy to insult our voters
and republican elected officials for
representing our voters views but it's
worse than just being silent laura on
china remember a couple years back they
actually thanked the government of
xinjiang province in china where they're
systematically trying to exterminate a
religious and ethnic minority putting
millions of them in concentration camps
so disney is actually worse than silent
on china disney has gone out of its way
to thank
the chinese communist officials who are
perpetrating genocide
that or tim cook from apple i don't know
which is worse but they're both really
bad thank you senator for your
leadership on this hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else